All right, this is a different sort of story.
Um, I don't want to go all like public service
announcement
on people, but I am so desperate to try to
figure out how we can solve this issue that
I feel obligated to say something about it
and that's that the texting while driving
just has to stop it. It is such a dangerous
behavior that is spreading like a virus. I
mean it's everywhere. And to be clear, I was
20 some years ago. I took more risks when
driving than I do today. I would go a little
too fast than I do a little faster than I.
Then I go today when it's icy out. I would
look at text messages here and there while
driving, but then respond when I was stopped
at a traffic light. But the degree to which
this behavior is leading to accidents and
deaths and destruction has become outrageous.
I, I'm finding myself almost at a loss for
words because it is everywhere.
I saw it in London last week, someone looking
down and texting while driving and just rolling
at 10 miles an hour, right through a red light
into an intersection and almost causing a
crash. On the highway here in Massachusetts.
I 90 called the mass pike inside of Massachusetts.
You can spot the texters from a mile away.
I start coming up on someone in the fast lane,
the left most lane and they're going 60 when
the speed limit is 65 and usually in the fast
lane you're going 70 or 75 to get around people.
I go over to the middle lane, arguably dangerous
in and of itself since you're not really supposed
to pass on the right but necessary to get
away from these people and I look over and
the person has no idea that they are creating
a backup in the fast lane looking down at
their phone and texting from a quarter mile
back.
You see someone's sort of meandering left
and right, not staying in their lane. It looks
like it could be a drunk driver, but it's
noon. Nope, not drunk. It's just someone on
their phone looking up only every other second.
And when you're going 40 or 50 or 60 you're
covering a lot of ground in that second when
you're not looking at the road here in Boston,
there are lots of sort of complicated four
and five way intersections. The city's known
for them. Some are always stopped, some are
two ways stops. Some are two. One ways that
meet and both have to turn onto another one
way and every week someone on their phone
misunderstands the intersection and almost
causes an accident that I see and I'm sure
that lots of them become real accidents that
I don't see. The number of near misses that
I've had with people who are merely on their
phones is certainly in the dozens.
And the thing about it is so many people who
do it think that their driving is not impaired.
Distracted driving is shown to be like drunk
driving. And in a sense it could even be worse
because people who are slightly buzzed will
often because they know that they will pay
extra attention when they're driving. Believe
me, I am not saying it's okay to drive when
buzzed. It's not. But people who do this with
their phones, they often don't say, Oh, I'm
doing something that is dangerous so I should
pay extra attention. In fact, they're doing
it the phone stuff because they believe that
it does not impair them in any way. And I've
actually had conversations with people who
say, you know, the thing about texting while
driving is some people can do it and some
people can't. Some people are good at it and
some are not.
I happen to be one of the people that can
do it. Uh, I'm not like those people who drive
bizarrely when they are texting and I'm sure
that it's a bell curve to some degree. Different
people are affected to different degrees when
they're texting while driving, but with so
many people doing it, wouldn't you want to
have all of your attention on the road to
make sure that some other distract the driver
doesn't run a red light or stop sign and hit
you. This is an area where not only strict
but likely to be enforced. Penalties seem
to make a difference, but that's the key thing.
They have to be likely to be enforced because
one of the things that we know is that it's
not just the severity of the punishment that
deters actions. We know that it doesn't in
many cases when you look at, for example,
the death penalty versus life in prison without
parole, it doesn't appear that the possibility
of the death penalty is a deterrent to people
committing murder.
But when you look at something like this or
when you look at, you know jaywalking is often
an example. It's a combination of not just
the severity of the punishment, but how likely
you are to get caught. I have friends in Sweden
who tell me, you know, I don't understand
what's going on in the U S the punishments
here are not only severe for drunk driving,
but they are likely to be enforced. We feel
like we are likely to be caught. So if we're
having one beer, maybe two, but in many cases,
even one beer, we don't drive. We get an Uber
or you get a designated driver or whatever,
you just don't chance it because it has taken
that seriously. I don't know what the solution
is here, especially with overloaded police
departments. Often by the way, overloaded
focusing on the wrong things like jailing
people for marijuana, but something has to
be done.
I don't know what it is. And there it seems
to be beyond reason. I don't know if it's
related to decrease the tension spans where
simply driving alone is not enough stimulus
for the brain where people feel like they
need to take out their phones and start scrolling
or texting. People are looking at Instagram.
I don't know what it is, but it's spreading
like a virus and I am open to hearing ideas
from people in the audience as to what it
is that should be done.